Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Fuck in April 30th,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
I'm,
I'm still sick.
Uh,
I just,
I've just,
every time I start to get healthy I travel again.
So I actually had to reschedule a Gig,
something I've never,
I don't,
can't remember the last time I did that.
So,
um,
cause I just need to fucking stay home and uh,
I'm just having coughing fits.
I'm having an absolute fucking fit at night.
Like my throat sounds like this.
I still got the sniffles and uh,
maybe I got a Bola,
you know?
Um,
but I'm kind of hot,
right?
I cough a little bit during the day,
but the second I lay down at night,
I also,
my throat gets all dry and I just have this cough.
It fit.
Now I'm saying this to you guys because all of you now without medical degrees
or now leaping to your feet and you know exactly what's wrong with me and what
the cure is.
And that's my favorite thing about being sick.
I like to not go to doctors.
I like to talk to people who have talked to doctors or went on web MD and then
they fucking diagnosed me.
So,
uh,
I just think I need to,
I need to shut it down for a couple of fucking days and a not do anything is
what I need to do it.
But I'm,
he avoid here am doing the fucking podcast.
Um,
I want to thank everybody that came out too in hot Lana
to the show at the Fox theater.
Um,
I know I sounded like shit,
but I think I had a good show.
Um,
and then the next day,
uh,
like an asshole rather than just being like,
Bill,
you sick,
you know,
don't do the plan.
Fun Event.
Just go home and sleep it off.
I couldn't lay off man.
I went to the Talladega super fucking speedway and I went to that Nascar race
out there man.
And uh,
just had a great,
great time.
Legendary,
legendary track.
That's where they always have the big one,
but big ones come,
you don't know when it's coming.
All you know,
all you really know is that it's common.
The big one is just they can drive.
So God damn fast there,
that event,
you know,
and then right on each other's bumpers.
Eventually all it takes is somebody to do a little Shimmy,
Shimmy,
sham,
shake,
whatever the fuck it is.
Shake and bake.
Choking on my own.
Spit right.
Do a little Ricky Bobby shit,
little Brewster baker,
little a stroke or race.
Trying to think of all the stock car movies I saw.
MMM.
Breathe in too many fumes.
Um,
and then they just have like a giant fucking uh,
crash there.
So you know the deal
it was Tony Stewart said,
we come,
we come there for the accidents.
I don't want to see anybody die,
but I want to see shit fly through the fucking air.
So we were in the suite,
then we watched like the first couple of legs of the race and then it was just
like,
dude,
I want to go outside and I want to fucking,
you know,
I want to hear the cars and all that shit.
So we went he upper deck,
which is the shit,
cause you can see the whole God damn track and then we will like,
let's go down low because it was more seats and we went down there and it's that
whole thing is like 40 fucking cars go by it like you know,
180,
190 200 miles an hour and all you thinking as if if they got,
if they have the big one right,
not right in front of me because by the time everything you know settles,
it's going to be fucking two miles down on me a quarter mile down the fucking
track.
It's like if it happens right before me,
there is a chance I could take a lug lug nut to the side of my head and uh,
I'll be fucking dead,
you know.
But uh,
it is amazing.
I got to tell you in the people down there,
we'll fucking great.
Um,
I've always been a fan of fucking Alabama.
It's a beautiful God damn state,
but I will,
I will tell you this,
not to get negative and shit,
just in general.
Uh,
there is a level of fucking poverty that you just cannot fucking,
but like some of the people,
some,
I just find them a long time ago,
Patrice O'neil told me this,
it was fucking hilarious.
He said,
you know,
some bill egos,
black people,
we are good at being broke.
And I go,
he talking about,
he goes,
look at us.
He goes,
we had,
we had the cleanest motherfuckers on the earth.
You wouldn't know that we're broke even if we are broke.
But I'll tell you something about white people when a white person is broke,
you fucking know it.
And uh,
that's what I was thinking about as I always do.
I always think of shit that he said and I just was looking at these fucking
people meant something.
Not all of them,
but just so was,
there's been a few when I've been traveling,
there's been a few times where I've seen little kids and I've had the urge to
rescue them.
You know,
by the time you look at the adults you like,
it's too late for him.
You know,
I've seen that in inner cities.
I sign in India and I saw it in Alabama.
Talladega,
not everybody.
I'm not saying everybody,
but there was definitely some fucking people.
I was like,
that kid,
if you get them out of this environment,
he has,
he's got fucking hope.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
I,
Oh,
you know something when you hear that shit white privilege and stuff,
you can say that to me.
But I always want,
like,
after going to that race,
I was wondering what those people think.
You know,
cause the,
the bus definitely skipped this stop.
Um,
and I'm not talking down on these people because I fucking hate how people up
north and people,
the coasts and everything.
They got this fucking attitude.
Like,
you know,
if she white and you're broke,
it's cause you had dump.
Um,
and that's just ignorant because you haven't fucking traveled.
But,
uh,
having said that,
there was a disturbing amount of confederate flags that I saw,
but like,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't,
I don't get that aspect of it,
but the other shit I'm just talking about.
She coming out of the side of your fucking sneakers.
Um,
I dunno.
It was,
it was,
it was interesting.
It definitely,
as a fellow American,
I was like,
you know,
we probably should be doing something about this.
Can we try to help these fucking people out now?
I know Trump said he was going to do what he was gonna make it great again.
And I can tell you right now that I didn't see a lot of greatness there.
Oh Shit.
Why did,
why do I talk about things?
Why do I see things and then talk about things.
You know what?
Cause that's what I do.
I didn't talk to,
you know,
I actually talked to a lot of people when I was there.
I had a good time,
but there was definitely a few people that just had to take pictures of,
you know,
but I'm not going to post them just because,
I don't want you,
I don't want to further ready sort of fucking stereotypes.
And the people in Nascar treated be great,
but there's definitely,
I saw this fucking guy he had on,
uh,
overall shorts because the only way to describe it it Larry Bird short shorts
and the whole thing was the American flag and cowboy boots with no shirt
underneath it,
shaved head and sunglasses.
You know,
he looked like Rob Halford on the 4th of July,
does the only way to describe it.
Um,
and he was standing next to a guy,
it just fucking bare feet look alike.
He walked out of a coal mine and uh,
it was fucking just some old school shit and people just smoking like chimneys,
like a lot of people smoking down there.
And it reminded me of when I was a kid,
like the level that people were smoking.
But having said that,
um,
it was also a bunch of other people that look fine.
I'm just saying,
but there was definitely some people you just like,
God damn,
that guy's fucking broke,
you know,
um,
how are you Hawaiian?
And you're that broke.
What they're saying out there is,
that's not supposed to happen.
You're supposed to just fucking wake up,
you know,
did every,
all the doors are supposed to swing open for you with your Hawaiian privilege?
Um,
well that happened for me.
People,
it did not happen for those people.
You know,
I,
you know what,
I think a lot of it goes back to,
I think it goes back to the civil war.
When you lose a fucking war,
like that dead,
the repercussions of that,
you deal with that for a long fucking time.
And uh,
you know,
I knew some people that relocated from the north down to the south back in the
80s.
Some friends of mine,
their parents moved or whatever,
and I just remember them calling me up and they're going,
dude,
I'm learning shit in school right now that I learned fucking two years ago up
north.
Right.
Okay,
this is fucking ridiculous.
There's no fucking reason for that.
There is no reason for that.
Um,
so I don't know,
did I mention the race was fucking awesome?
Um,
I was just a little taken aback by shit like that.
You know,
you don't like to see that.
You don't like to see that anyway.
Right.
I don't like seeing people struggling,
you know,
not having the answers walking around and Jean shorts.
Um,
but anyways,
great fucking food at the track.
Jesus Christ.
It was delicious food.
I had this barbecued fucking a something or other,
but the Cole slaw on it and everything was absolutely delicious.
And uh,
and I love the track,
legendary track.
And then I love the fucking,
the bleachers.
It was just no frills,
no bullshit.
You know,
looked like an old football stadium.
Whether it's just like we just build in fucking seats.
That's it.
No fucking Sushi stands and under that crap.
Um,
it's definitely a good time.
I hope that didn't come off like a,
some,
a leader.
She Yankee thing.
Anyways,
plowing ahead now.
Now we're going to get into my elitist
attitude for the weekend.
And this is something that everybody's going to be like first world problem and
all that.
I have a fucking problem with Delta Airlines.
All right?
These fucking assholes
for whatever reason,
they board first class and their premium select whatever they call them,
they're fucking medallion members at the same fucking time.
You know all these widgets,
salesman that fly every fucking weekend.
It's like I spent 20 years in the back of the fucking plane with the stress of
the back of the plane.
Okay.
Like fuck,
I need to line up an hour before the flight so I get on early enough.
So there's going to be a place for my fucking bag.
Okay.
And was this a DC 9:00 AM I is is the engine right outside my window and a
part's gonna fly off into my fucking head at my next to the bathroom.
Okay.
You're going to smell the piss and shit of the fuck at work in class.
I spent 20 years in the back of that fucking plane and they kept us back there
and we didn't get on it till FirstClass got on and we were not allowed past that
fucking curtain.
That was their fucking bathroom.
Okay.
I did every Goddamn Hell Gig.
I had shit thrown at me,
got booed.
I got fucked out of money and I moved up the row spot.
Baba Baba Baba.
Well,
I got up to the exit
Riley at that,
that,
uh,
I got all the way up there.
Now I can finally afford
okay
to set up front.
Right.
And I don't give a fuck that day.
Like anybody with a limp or a yeast infection.
Anybody active military,
even if you never saw action,
even if all you do is counter grenades rather than fucking throw him,
you can get on first.
I don't give a fee.
Got a stroller and a kid.
You're old in,
in a wheelchair and I'm a fucking problem with that.
These fucking assholes.
They take all their frequent flyers and then these fucking fucking cunts.
All right.
They line up like a half hour before.
So I'm like,
where's the first class line?
They go,
it's right here.
I look back,
I'm like 40th in fucking line and now I've got the anxiety again.
Okay.
That's not,
that is not FirstClass FirstClass as you walk on without a fucking care in the
world,
that's what I paid for.
I walk on without a care in the world and you pretend that are better than the
people behind me.
That is what I'm paying for.
And that is not the experience you get on Delta Airlines.
All of these fucking people just fucking love.
Why can't you just bought first class in two seconds later I had those fucking
premium cuts.
They line up like a half hour before.
Now I've got to stand up.
I don't even use frequent flyer.
I pay full price for the fucking ticket cause I can't figure out how to do the
fucking,
I don't even want to figure it out.
We'll figure out,
you know how many fucking miles I have with you assholes?
What is the ticket price?
Hey,
you go the way a guy shops.
I'm not waiting for the sale.
I need pants.
Those are pants.
What are they here?
This is given to me.
So I fucking get on the plane and I get on a plane and all First Class fucking
bids a take it.
I see one,
one let's like fucking two rows behind me and I feel that that fucking anxiety,
that fucking anxiety that gave me the drive to get up to the front of the
fucking plane
and then I'm sitting there,
right?
I finally fucking sit out in all of this shit.
Right?
And um,
I know you guys are like,
Bill quit your fucking whining.
Fuck you is what I say?
Yeah,
I'll say it again.
Fuck you.
All right.
Don't call it fucking first class and don't charge me for first guy.
Want a first class experience.
You know,
so many people sit in the back of the plane.
Let's say you went on wheel of fortune and you solve the fucking puzzle.
All right?
And they said that they were going to give you a first class accommodations in
Laughlin,
Nevada.
All right,
well if you came walking into the hotel and you didn't get to go to VIP Checkin,
you still does stand in line with all these flip flop wearing fucking overeaten
jackasses.
Yeah.
Is that the first class experience?
You know what I mean?
They treated me like a $3 whore.
You got a $3 whore,
you're expecting a certain level of attitude,
but when you get a $1,200 to $2,000 fucking call girl,
she supposed to pretend you're interesting and your stories are fascinating that
you're paying for the experience.
I'm just letting you know that experience does not exist on Delta Airlines.
Yeah,
you're going to get on the fucking plane with the first class seat that you
fucking paid for with 40 other fucking people in front of you with their neck
braces and they're fucking and got all this a bonds they need because those poor
bastards are still sitting in the back of the play.
Okay,
well I paid good money.
I paid good God damn money for the fantasy that I am above those people and I
did not get that.
And I hope Mister and Missus Delta Airlines here,
this fucking thing and I hope,
I hope they try to come at me with some sort of voucher,
some sort of gift certificate for a Brownie Sundae.
The next time I go back to the Atlanta Jackson fucking airport.
Okay.
This is the thing.
All this fucking waving my arms.
They're not going to fucking change it.
They're not going to change it.
And I'm still going to fly.
They're fucking airline when I have to,
cause I don't have any,
I don't have any little,
I'm,
I'm basically an American Airlines guy.
You know an American Airlines.
When you fly first class,
you do,
you just eat,
you get on with the first class people,
you sit down,
you fucking fine.
You know what you are,
you're an inspiration.
You're an inspiration to the rest of those passions.
There's passages that walk past you on American Airlines.
Okay?
They're looking at you go and look at that and sickly bald looking redheaded
guy.
If I work hard and those Sunday I'll be him
getting on the plane without a care in the fucking world.
It's like Delta Airlines.
Yeah.
You getting on with those same fucking people.
You know,
those people that are so fat,
they got the crease in the back like a toddler.
You know,
toddlers have those cute rolls of fat.
You know what I mean?
There's a certain level of fatty you get to,
you should really have your arms up.
You know,
the way a little baby walks.
Uh,
why am I attacking fat people?
I,
I just,
I've traveled.
I didn't even know how many fucking miles I traveled,
but let's put it this way.
When I saw that George Clooney movie where he was trying to get a million miles,
I wasn't impressed.
All right?
But that man was doing was pedestrian.
Oh,
and then you met the woman you found out later.
She was married.
Welcome to the fucking road buddy.
Am I supposed to feel bad for you with your full head of beautiful salt and
pepper?
Fucking hair.
Hang on a sec.
You've villain Indian fucking Italy.
Um,
my stocking him.
All right.
And one is life anyways.
Um,
yeah,
I just don't like that Delta has put me in the position to expose myself for the
elitist cunt that I am.
All right.
I'm not saying that I'm better than the people in the back of the plane.
What I'm saying is,
is I got paid to be treated better than them and I don't want to be lumped in
with all these fucking contest winners,
all these fucking widget salesman that fly your goddamn airline every fucking
fucking weekend.
So then now this down they port.
What the fuck did they pay for their ticket?
300 bucks.
You getting on with me?
How dare you put me in that position?
Delta,
Mrs and Mrs Delta Airlines.
Okay.
They should be,
I should've got a fucking discount on my tea.
I just wished it was a fucking phone number that you could call and actually
talk to a person and I could just be like the biggest asshole ever.
What don't they get on your airline?
I do not even want to shoot people beyond the other facility that occurred
during the fucking flight.
Like people just waltzed and write up.
Just using the fucking bat.
Everybody gets on.
Everybody's in first place the fuck Outta here.
Get outta here with euro comedy,
condoms,
seating,
shits.
You take those in the back,
buddy.
You take that in the back.
I don't want to listen to your fucking sin up on farts up here.
Okay.
This is first class.
We have silverware.
No,
I don't give a shit if fuse about,
I don't give a fuck about any of it.
The only thing I fucking want is what I'm paying for is you go first class and I
just Mosey on to the fucking plane and stick my bag right above my chair and I
sit in a chair that's actually fit to be used by a human being.
That's all I'm fucking paid for.
I don't give a fuck about your meals and all of that other bullshit and then he
call me mister burn as in fuck,
you can take my fucking Hoodie and go hang it up.
I don't give a fuck about all of that.
Okay.
I'm paying for no anxiety.
Like if this is the pain going to be there.
Okay.
I all of that is supposed to be God.
You know,
it's like winning the lottery.
That's what flying first classes you flight.
This is the thing about for you fly first class.
You don't want the flight to end.
That's how great first class is supposed to be.
Delta has somehow lost it.
They forgot what the fuck it was.
You know what I mean?
You know what?
I blame all of this on.
Ah,
right.
You know what?
I blame all of this shit on fucking dress casual Fridays.
Casual Fridays.
Fucking ended it.
Okay.
It fucking ended it in this goddamn country.
I'm old enough to remember when all of a sudden casual Fridays,
how old I am.
I remember when that shit came out at somebody.
I was working in the warehouse and somebody from the carpeted area
just started working there.
You know what I mean?
Those during the,
this is the eighties this is like the Michael J.
Fox Erez.
So you know what I mean?
He got yourself a skinny tie in a fucking cubicle and you bought a Ford probe,
you know?
Okay.
Whatever the fuck they used to call those fucking cars.
You've got like a a Subaru,
you know,
and this fucking little Michael J.
Fox guy goes,
what's,
what's casual Fridays?
And I made the joke.
I go all that's when everybody dresses like us.
Basically.
Like your run loading a truck.
And I remember my boss got upset by that and tried to have some big fucking
meeting about it and I'm Mr. Burns said that that's when everybody drives
dresses like us and a that's stuck with me a,
I feel like we should have more pride out here in the warehouse and fucking
bookbub and you just,
it,
he had a bunch of fucking hung over musicians in class.
Clowns working out there and just staring at this guy going to be showing up.
Like we always show up.
Okay.
If you think I'm going to fucking show up like it's the 1950s and we work at an
ice cream parlor to go unload trucks.
That's not happening.
So that failed.
But um,
okay.
Yeah,
everything has just become like everybody's just fucking down to earth now.
Sort of as the middle class shrinks,
I don't understand it.
Okay.
Do you know back in the day when you flew first,
this is how far we fucking come.
When you flew first class on Pan Am and you flew into JFK international airport
back before every airport said they were international.
You know what I mean?
That's like every fucking podcasts out there claims they have like a million
fucking downloads or the number one in something.
You know what I mean?
Every fucking airport now since they're international.
Well you know,
you connect from our airport to an actual international airport and next thing
you know you're in Europe.
So I think we're international.
That's like the second assistant hockey.
The Fuck Outta here.
Second assist.
You knew that fucking guy was going to pass it to the other guy.
You get a point too.
Um,
okay.
Oh fuck my train of thought.
What was,
what was my point?
Oh,
back in the day,
the metlife building in New York,
right at Bro,
a right above grand central station used to be the Pan Am building.
Well back in the day when you flew first class in Pan Am,
you landed at JFK.
He got off that fucking plane from up top where there was a guy playing a
goddamn piano.
Okay.
You're up there this summer when came blowing in.
Won't your sock my day?
Great.
This is nothing too.
People go,
well,
what happened to all the good looking stewardesses and all that?
Oh look,
because there's no money.
They deregulated the whole fucking thing and then that'd be fucking jerk off
with flip flops could use to FirstClass bathroom and then all those good looking
women and like,
well there's no nobody to gold.
Dig On this thing.
I'm fucking Outta here.
That's what happened.
Okay.
You take the money,
the money goes out the window sodas,
all the beautiful women.
It's like a vacuum.
They get sucked,
right the fuck out.
Everybody on the flight looks like [inaudible] Alice from the Brady Bunch.
Oh God.
Ugh.
Drinking this fucking cold and flu herbal shot.
Oh God.
That's gotta be the Dandelions or some shit.
Oh my God.
That's bitter.
Anyways,
I'm sweating.
I'm gonna Finish this fucking story.
When you flew first class on Pan Am to JFK international airport,
when you got off that fucking plane,
you didn't go into the airport with those.
You did.
You got off that fucking thing and they walked you over to a fucking helicopter.
Okay.
And you like Ron Burgundy,
you know with a scarf around your neck and you have glass of Scotch.
You fucking walked over to that thing.
You got on that,
they flew you from Brooklyn right up and over.
All the traffic landed you on top of the Pan Am building and you know what was
up there.
There was a bar,
beautiful women,
rich people and all this shit.
You got off into that world and you had another scotch.
Okay.
You talked to some women and whatever,
right?
Well you made a fucking business connection and then when you were ready to go,
somebody took your bags,
you went down in the elevator and right into a fucking cab over to you.
God Damn Hotel.
Yeah.
And probably somebody put a little fucking eight ball and your breast coat
pocket.
We've gone from that
to what I experienced in Atlanta and mister and Missus Delta Airlines.
Okay.
I missed it.
I missed,
okay.
That my window
of when FirstClass was first class,
that she sometimes you just got to admit that you missed it.
Like,
I feel bad for millennials,
like when I look at all this shit that they're going through and all these
climate change and all this crap that they gonna have to fucking deal with,
the ramifications of,
I look back,
you know,
as I'm dealing with turning 50 I'm like,
you know what,
it's kind of cool that I got to live through the seventies eighties and nineties
you know,
and I'd take one out now when I look at people in their sixties seventies and
eighties and I'm thinking like,
you know what,
that guy right there,
that guy probably got his dick sucked on a helicopter ride from JFK over to the
top of the Pan Am building.
That guy knows what first class
is.
All right.
Um,
I don't want to hear it.
I don't want to hear it from the people in the back of the plane.
What a spoiled Brat I am.
I don't give a fuck.
I am so beyond you
that I won't even read your emails.
I can tell by the font that you sit in the back of the plane where you have a
law.
No,
I'm kidding.
I'm just saying.
You know what I mean?
What the fuck can I just get on the fucking plane?
All I'm asking for,
I don't need a helicopter ride.
I don't need a fucking hand job.
Can I just get on the fucking plane in a relaxed manner?
Just put my bag up there.
This was the fuck I paid for.
Okay.
And then you can come to me and be like,
um,
do you,
you want the eggs?
So the oatmeal,
can I get the eggs on Saturday?
Where all out of eggs that happens in first class.
What do we do around eggs as far as class?
So I'm,
my voice is cracking his first fucking class.
You should still have them.
Hang on a second.
Let me take another shot of fucking dandelion root.
Oh,
I'm starting to like that.
But as we went,
I did the landscape,
but for fucking one song,
all right.
In,
don't cheat.
You know,
talk about how every man looks better in a suit.
Oh yeah.
Every man,
it looks better to suit,
especially back in the day when FirstClass as first class and you would wear a
suit trying to impress those goddesses that used to work up there,
you know,
and they pretended that you were funny and that your stories were fucking
interesting and then they fucking dance gov over to a Goddamn helicopter and
you're beautiful fitted suit and don't.
Chino is the world's largest made to measure men's wear company and has been
featured in major publications including Gq.
Ooh,
Forbes
and fast company.
Yeah.
I don't know what that last one is.
It kind of tapered off in the last one,
Huh?
Um,
they make suits and shirts made to your exact measurements for great fit.
Guys.
Love the wide selection of high quality fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including your lapel lining and monogram.
Here's how it works.
Visit a showroom or shop online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
choose your customizations,
submit your measurements,
wait for your custom suit to arrive at just a few weeks.
This week's,
my listeners can get any premium.
I hate that word at this point.
After watching what the premium people got getting to board at the same time is
my privileged white freckle das.
Any premium Indochino suit for just 379 bucks.
It indochino.com when entering bur bur a checkout that's 50% off the regular
price for a made to measure premium suit plus shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code [inaudible] for any premium suit for just $379
and free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit you better than anything off the rack
ever could.
All right,
I'll look who it is.
It's the black Tux.
Just like the Ohio state dude.
The fucking love this shift.
This Dan the line stop.
Mm.
Oh Jesus.
What a fucking after taste them.
Then it gets good.
Starts tasting metallic.
Um,
Joan is Straw.
Uh,
the Black Tux,
the Black Tux wedding season is upon us.
I'm so happy I'm in the other.
So you know,
sometimes when I see somebody in a wedding,
I'm just,
I'm so glad that I'm on the other side of that,
you know?
And then I look at people that have started a family and they're done having
kids,
you know,
cause it was debating possibly having another one.
I don't know.
I'm pretty fucking old at this point.
What am I,
Tony Randall.
Um,
but like when I just see so many that said they're married,
they have demount of kids that they're going to have and they're just on the
other side of it.
Okay.
They've taken the date,
date,
they set sail and this is what we're doing.
You know that together the shit is working.
You know?
Even though I had,
I would have one,
I had one of the great weddings of all time and it's such a great time,
man.
It just,
the stress,
you know,
I have anxiety,
I have anxiety.
I think that's what it is.
I'm almost thinking like,
like where,
where,
where's the fucking slap to the side of the head comes from.
Um,
anyways,
wedding season is upon us.
You're going to be doing it big and going all out.
All right,
go on.
Going out to all of your buddies weddings.
Nice copy.
I liked at your buddy's wedding.
So you're not,
you're not the one locked and loaded.
You're not locked in.
You're not getting waterboarded.
You're the free guy.
Run around with your bow tie off,
banging all the fucking drunk chicks.
When you're bringing a date,
you want to look fresh.
Uh,
but it has to be convenient.
Who brings a fucking day to a wedding?
That's the dumbest thing you could ever do.
When are you going to add comedienne Yay.
That's where the black tux comes at.
Fuck deck.
You've got to Tuck.
She goes stag.
Uh,
the black Tux has answered.
It has awesome suits and Tuxedos and all kinds of styles and you rent them
online.
There you go.
You get up,
you get a Tuxedo with a little bit of flair.
You show up,
you know,
with your little Pompadour,
you just,
all you gotta do is act like you're interesting.
You know,
the anxiety that women feel at a wedding,
that it's not them.
I'm telling you right now that they're going to fall right in your fucking lap.
Um,
just wait for a slow song to come on.
You know,
we both last Saturday,
steely in the dead of that who would have poison at their wedding at this point?
Somebody getting married for the third time.
Uh,
the black,
the black Tux,
the kinds of suits and Tuxedos styles that would normally be wildly expensive to
buy.
And you might only wear it once like the Emerald Shawl Tuxedo.
It's Funky motherfucker.
It's cool.
But how many times you get to wear it?
How many times you going to wear an Emerald Green Tuxedo?
Uh,
with the black Tux you can do,
you can do you and blow it out for your big one big one time event.
I can't read anymore with the Black Tux.
Free home.
Try-On you can see the fit and feel the quality of your suit months before your
event.
After a watery orders,
you know,
against all balls.
Your suit will arrive 14 days before your event.
If anything is less than perfect,
the black Tux will send you a replacement right away.
And remember how simple returns are where it turned heads.
Then send it back three days after your event.
Shipping is free both ways.
Stand out at your event for the right reasons with the Black Tux to get $20 off
your purchase,
visit the Black tux.com/bird that's the black tux.com/birth for $20 off your
purchase.
The black Tux premium rental suits and Tuxedos delivered.
Oh my God,
I got two more of these.
Oh,
but the nice and short,
because these people understand my intellect.
A dollar shave club,
dude,
if you have a shower or brush your teeth to try to make you a hey look
presentable.
Here's some good news.
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to help you out.
Dollar Shave Club.
Yes,
that's dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best.
You name it.
Shampoo,
conditioner,
body wash,
toothpaste,
Hair Gel.
Even a wipe did alleviate tush feeling tingling and clean,
so fresh and so clean.
You'll be a big fan of their amber and lavender calming bog body cleanser.
After you try it the first time,
I just immediately envisioned someone stealing my fucking kidneys after they put
that shit on me.
Uh,
good luck.
Finding a product that great at the store.
All of dollar shave club's products are made with top shelf ingredients that
won't break your budget.
You feel the difference.
Plus shipping is free with your membership.
The only thing they're missing is a loop for you to rub one out with.
And here's a great way to get a bunch of dollar shave club products for just
five bucks.
You can get their daily essential status set.
It comes with body cleanser would wipe Chimichurri.
They're amazing,
but wipes.
They're world famous shave and their best razors.
This six blade executive,
keep the blades coming for a few more bucks a month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste,
or anything else you need.
Speaking of your next month,
for a limited time,
only use code birth checkout to get $5 off your second month or the club.
That's Code bar@dollarshaveclub.com to save $5 on your second month.
Join the club today.
All right.
stamps.com everybody,
I think I need a shot at dandelion juice here.
Hmm.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
my wife asked me.
She goes,
what does that taste like?
I said burnt eyelashes.
I don't even know what,
that's just the first thing I thought.
stamps.com use postal you,
US Postal Service is an important tool for any business.
stamps.com is the easiest way to access all the amazing services of the post
office.
stamps.com never fucking closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven wait postage for any male class right now for your computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underplay or overplay again.
I can mail any letter,
any package using just my computer and printer and the mail carrier picks it up.
Mail everything from postcards to envelope to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps.com account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and
no longterm commandments.
I use stamps.com because I have a new poster coming out from my new tour that's
simply called 50.
Um,
and not 50,
not 50 cents 50.
As in this old white man is half a century old.
Um,
and I will be selling and I need to get those things over to fucking Dublin and
to London.
And to wherever the fuck else.
I'm going to be a and I use stamps.com because if I could figure it out.
So can you are right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstamps.com enter
berm.
All right,
let's talk hockey.
Play off play offs.
You can make
playoffs.
Um,
God damn it.
That was fucking delicious.
It's some free appetite.
Doctors,
shelters,
cold and flu herbal shot.
The aftertaste is terrible,
but whatever remains on your tongue is incredible.
I like it.
Remember that Chevy Chase?
We did that giant line of blow.
Um,
ah,
I like it.
Um,
nothing subbed up the 70s and the 80s,
like that quick little joke.
Alright.
Hockey playoffs,
the borough,
it's jumped all over Tampa Bay in game one.
Um,
to go up one,
nothing.
Um,
once again,
our top line was absolutely killing it to Karasik was playing fucking great.
Um,
to Brasco whatever.
I already know half the guys fucking these.
We were like,
when I'm in the other room and somebody scores,
a lot of the time I have to poke my head in to see who it is because we change
so many players to this season.
And with the kid I,
I probably watched five full games and um,
anyways,
and then gave to Tampa was just a better team.
They just came out like a,
they were ready to play and we just,
I don't know,
every time we had the pocket was like,
it was on edge and um,
so whatever,
it's one to one,
but we did what we had to do.
We want one down there and that will come back.
And uh,
I hope we get up.
I'm more competent officiating crew because those guys were just,
it was like they were off and whatever.
They made some fucking bad calls.
But that happens sometimes the calls go your way.
Sometimes they don't,
you don't whine about it.
You pick up and move on.
But you know,
when the fucking net is off the goddamn moorings,
whatever the fuck they call it in the,
and the goalies like dope.
Oh here for like a half a fucking minute.
And they just don't see it like date that was not ready for primetime
officiating.
Um,
you know,
I just hope I just don't want it to come down to that.
Cause I think that Tampa is a great team and I want,
I want to see Tampa beat us or the Bruins beat them.
I,
I just,
you know,
that is a pet peeve of mine that,
you start calling ticky tack Shit and you start like,
you know,
dictating the tone of the game and then all of a sudden you stop calling ticky
tack Shit.
It's just weird.
You know what I mean?
And then you let that shit go and then all of a sudden you call and stuff.
I mean that's the type of shit,
you know,
back in the day when I used to watch the NBA was like,
what the fuck?
You know,
the shit is fixed.
Uh,
speaking of the NBA,
I was working a Saturday night and missed everything about that Celtics game
seven against Milwaukee.
I have not even seen a highlight.
I am very happy that we won.
I heard we kind of want it,
you know,
wire to wire.
And uh,
and then last night,
the weirdest thing ever.
Like this Boston Celtics had a fucking playoff game while the Bruins had a
playoff game and we beat the,
the,
the formidable Philadelphia 70 sixers.
Uh,
when is that next game?
And I can't,
I last time I think we played each other in the playoffs.
I have to go back to like 80 to 81,
82 83
way back in the day.
All right.
Game too is when Thursday.
Well,
I hope that's not going to overlap with the Bruins.
Fuck am I supposed to do,
I want to see this,
um,
the overachieving Celtics with all the goddamn injuries.
This is tremendous.
And um,
my picks in the NBA finals before it started and you can check
with the great and always lovely to Elmira.
That's what I've always loved about his act.
It's not the top shelf joke writing,
it's the elegance of his performance.
Um,
I,
he asked me will,
I thought and I picked a Toronto in the and golden state cause I figured Golden
State and Cleveland we're going to,
one of them is gonna make it back.
And uh,
I dunno,
I'm just impressed with Toronto.
They just got a lot of weapons and shit and blah,
blah blah blah blah.
And like Lebron is played like the equivalent of 60 years with all the fucking
playoffs that,
that guy has been involved in.
Um,
so anyways,
those are,
those are my goddamn pics and as far as hockey
goes,
um,
yeah,
I dunno.
It's hard to
go against the penguins getting back there again.
But I think the most interesting series right now is obviously the predators in
Winnipeg jets.
Um,
I would not want to have to play either one of them and I'm sites.
One of them is going to knock the other one off.
All right.
There's my limited fucking view of what the fuck's going on.
Alright.
Punk suggestions.
The fuck did you call me?
Um,
all right.
I was listening to your podcast and you asked someone for suggestions on
hardcore punk music.
I thought I'd try and email you from here.
I would start with bands like minor threat.
I've heard of them.
Food Gazi I've heard of them.
The X.
Never heard of them.
Bad brains.
Of course I've heard of them.
He wrote,
of course a negative approach.
Parentheses,
pretty aggressive.
Death from Detroit.
These are few good starters.
I hope this message reaches you and you enjoy.
All right,
I'll check those up.
I'm still trying to get into fish.
Everybody.
They haven't quite grab me.
Alright.
Bullshit.
Guy Needing ar 15 to defend against coyotes.
Oh my God.
He's in the middle of fucking nowhere.
He's making you cheese.
Hey Sir.
William [inaudible].
I'm calling bullshit on the guy who wrote in claiming he needs an ar 15 to
protect his goats from coyotes.
All right.
Okay,
well I hope you're a gun owner and a fucking rancher.
I grew up in a rural town in New Mexico.
All right.
I wasn't a plumber shown cheese rancher,
but we had two sheepdogs and Adeno coyotes living directly behind our house to
this day.
Every night you could hear the coyotes howling.
The guy doesn't need a machine gun.
He needs more than one dog.
Oh Shit.
Shots fired.
Seems like common sense.
Honestly.
There are breeds of dogs that have been bred for centuries to protect sheep from
wolves.
Well,
that is true.
And they didn't have machine guns back then.
Well,
how is like a one sheeped are two sheepdogs fend off our herd at coyotes.
You know what that sounds like.
That sounds like the sheepdogs at play in basketball and the coyotes are doing
some man one shit.
They need to have a fucking team game and they got to feed that big man under
the fucking rack and quit putting up threes with no one who?
Nobody underneath.
All right,
wait a second.
Uh,
there are breeds of dogs that had been bred for centuries to protect sheep from
wolves.
Coyotes are pussies compared to wolves.
A few times when I was a kid,
I was less than 15 free from an adult coyote.
And it just ran away.
Coyotes are also a lot smaller than wolves claiming coyotes hunt in packs of
seven to 12.
Seems like an exaggeration.
I don't like that word.
Seems.
That seems to me like you don't know,
but it just sounds like bullshit to you.
Anyways,
the most baddest thing I've ever seen a dog do was when my neighbors psycho dog
chased away a coyote that came near as turf.
My neighbor had this crazy ugly mutt named butch.
Butch was the kind of dog where if the football or baseball went over the fence
into butches yard,
the ball was gone one day when I was a teenager and I was walking up the road
and there was a coyote walking near me.
I wasn't scared because the coyote was just minding his own business.
I any fucking wild.
They're wild.
Animals have a different look on their face.
Okay?
They,
they're killers.
You know,
it's like hookers.
So you know,
there's a different look at,
don't know,
Hook.
It looks at you.
It's real.
All right?
They're not fucking just trying to get a drink out of you.
Uh,
then I see a butch jump over this five foot wall in land in a dead sprint quote.
Oh Jesus.
This is going to be good.
I thought he beeline straight for the coyote and without any hesitation or fear
hit the coyote like Walter Payton on cocaine.
It definitely would have been on sports center is top 10 or some youtube video
hardest hits in the NFL.
I love that you went with Walter Payton.
He was one of the most aggressive,
uh,
offensive players.
Larry's Onco is the first offensive player to get an unnecessary roughness call.
He was on his way out of bounds.
If someone went to hit him and he just gave the guy a forearm shiver to the
face,
then butch and the coyote got into a scrappy ghetto street fight and eventually
the coyote ran away.
This all happened within 10 yards of where I was standing.
Uh,
well that was just one.
And it sounds like the coyote fucking threw some hands too though.
Okay.
Dogs are bad ass.
They can recognize threats and step up with no fear.
They also used to be wolves.
They're like,
we'll,
we'll flight,
right?
Yeah.
MMM.
I'm not saying it's a good light beer.
It's more like Busch lite.
Surely this guy can find some large dogs who have instincts to protect some
goats rather than resort to a military machine.
Gun Shooting coyotes for sport is Douchey.
My uncle,
it has an
what are they?
Anatolian shepherd.
Okay.
And it was apparently bread for guarding livestock.
Livestock.
Massive dog.
Uh,
I have a good summer and go fuck yourself.
Well,
what's the overhead?
What's the overhead on the dog?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Look at that guy.
Damn thing.
The males way from 50 to 65 kilograms,
which is 110 to 143 pounds.
Females of 40 to 55 kilograms,
that's 88,
221 pounds.
Uh,
they're like 32 inches.
29 to 32 inches high.
28 to 31 inches high.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
That's a big ass God damn dog.
What's look at the car,
the coyotes.
The tale of the tape here.
Coyote stats.
This is going to take me to the Phoenix coyotes.
Coyote animal,
Wikipedia.
Let's see what you got here.
Actual Coyote or a man?
No.
Coyote attacks on humans.
Yeah.
Tax generally identify the animal in question as simply coyote.
Okay.
Uh,
what the eastern Caio East and Kiara.
Here we go.
See what they,
they don't even have their stats.
I don't like that.
That's like when a movie goes to the theaters without being reviewed.
The eastern coyotes is a wild North American canine of mixed coyote,
wolf and dog parentage parentage that is present in New England,
New York,
New Jersey,
Pennsylvania.
Hi Alyse fucking places.
Uh,
so they're basically like stray dogs that then got fucked by wolves.
Is that what happened?
That didn't get killed.
All right.
Okay.
I don't care anymore.
All right,
well,
you know,
some people,
he got 150 pound fucking dog.
I mean,
what do you got to feed that thing every day?
Okay.
How much of bullets?
I mean,
I don't know if it's like a,
I don't know.
Hey,
the guy who wrote in with the Parmesan cheese farm in fed a cheese,
let me know what,
what,
what do you think about what this guy's saying?
Yeah.
How many as far as I'm concerned.
What the fuck he just said.
You got Swiss cheese on your farm now buddy.
Got a bunch of holes in your argument.
Please write back.
Alright,
cops use DNA to,
I can't say this word genie a lot while g website,
genealogy,
genealogy.
All right,
let's look this up.
G E N e a.
L.
O.
G.
Y.
Pro.
None situation.
I love this.
This is just for dumb fucking people.
How to pronounce genealogy.
That is it.
Here we go.
Genealogy,
genealogy a lot.
Why is it genealogy?
One more time.
Hey.
Hello.
Love.
They say like five times genealogy.
Genealogy.
Yeah.
Like,
like why did you just pick a man or a woman?
You know,
like I can't hear it.
Oh,
now that,
that lady said it now and I know how to say it or what if a woman's listening?
Well,
I can't understand it unless a woman says it.
Okay.
Genealogy cops use DNA to
genealogy.
Website to website.
What?
Yeah,
it does.
Okay.
Hey.
Oh,
Billy bald con.
I just read the police caught the golden state killer using DNA obtained from
genealogy,
genealogy.
Website,
one of those DNA slash genealogy genealogy chill.
She websites that's going to make our robot replacements.
The DNA website responded by saying while in the debate,
while in while the database was created for genealogical research,
it is important that g e D match.
Oh,
people who didn't fucking graduate high school participants understand the
possible use of their DNA,
including identification of relatives that may have committed crimes or victims
of crimes.
Okay.
I know you're no legal analysts,
but I wanted to get your thoughts on this by the way.
Loved you on crashing.
Also come to a show in Maine for Fox sexy.
I'm due to go up there.
Have a nice day and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I don't think you can get mad at,
uh,
okay.
The fact that they caught a serial killer,
if that's,
if they got the right guy.
And you know what it was,
was it actually wasn't that guy from what I heard was it was a relative and it
was close enough and then they just narrowed it down into that gene pool and
they judge that guy by his age,
stay staked out his fucking house and then they got like a soda can out of his
garbage and got his fucking DNA and they nailed them.
Um,
yeah.
It's one of those things where this could be a great thing and you could get a
rid of a,
it's,
it's all how it's applied.
Okay.
And,
um,
human beings do not have a great track record of doing the right thing.
We are all susceptible to the seven deadly sins.
We are horribly flawed organisms.
And then when you combine racism,
sexism,
Homophobia,
uh,
greed,
ego and all of that shit,
uh,
yeah.
Like I don't know what could happen,
but I mean,
I mean,
I'm all for this,
this fucking guy and he's like 71.
I still feel like he kinda got away with it.
But,
um,
just for the victims are still alive or family members knowing that they got
this guy and he's going to fucking rot in jail for the rest of his fucking piece
of shit.
Life I think is a good thing.
Um,
oh my God,
it just came up with an idea for a movie.
A serial killer kills all his relatives before they go on to fucking a genealogy
website.
Genealogy website.
Geology website.
Yeah,
it's a comedy.
You know,
they're going to find out that he's the fucking a jet ski killer is some Shit.
I Dunno.
And then he's,
he's gotta be like,
you know,
any never goes to social events within the family.
He's always been a loner.
All of a sudden he starts showing up.
It's all the Christmas parties and he's asking questions.
Every party somebody dies.
So he's got like 10 family members and you know,
the first one he kills it.
Thanksgiving,
maybe Halloween,
thanksgiving,
then Christmas,
then there's like a fucking graduation.
I Dunno.
He just flag day he takes out his fucking uncle.
Um,
and then the local cops,
you know,
they've never seen anything like that.
They were in a quiet town to use that trope.
And all of a sudden there's this family members,
they're all dying,
you know,
and then everybody feels bad for the fucking loner cause he's losing all his
family members.
And then finally,
one day,
the fucking,
you know,
op start,
you got the phone,
good old sheriff,
you know,
he's seen everything.
God.
And I'm too old for this shit.
And then he got the ups to,
I don't fucking,
you finished the fucking Robie.
He finished the fucking movie.
I don't have time for that shit.
All right.
Black Republicans.
Everybody.
Dear Mr Burn,
I very much enjoyed your show at the Fox in Atlanta.
I went with my wife's parents in loss.
Thank you for your laughs and perspectives.
Well,
thank you.
Would you mind sharing your thoughts on Kanye,
his recent comments and the backlash from Hollywood and democratic elites?
Um,
why do they always say elites to this republican elites to I myself am a black
Republican who changed parties after the first Clinton administration for a
great many reasons.
It's a bit unnerving.
Hearing people cringe over the idea of a black Republican.
And it is disrespectful to marginalize my opinions in articulations because of
my affiliations.
It's very telling that people do.
Friend who defended Kanye and champion to him when he attacked George Bush are
now casting him aside because he just not agree with their group.
Think thank you for your service.
I go fuck yourself.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I,
there's this whole thing with liberals that they feel like all races are uh,
yeah,
Republicans and then they also aren't of their own fucking racist thoughts.
Prejudice starts and fucked up.
If you really pay attention to your thoughts,
the information your brain is going to give you during the course of a fucking
day,
you're going to think sexist shit,
homophobic shit,
racist.
You just going to think shit that if you set it out loud,
I've always said that if everybody's thoughts were made public,
could anybody go to work on Monday?
Would you have a fucking job?
And you would.
So I'm
on the other side.
The fact that Trump didn't tweet once during black history month said nothing as
far as I'm aware of on the 50th anniversary of Martin Luther King.
The fact that he fucking,
uh,
could kind of see both sides with neo Nazis and people who didn't like me and
Nazis said,
you know,
both sides of violent.
Um,
I,
uh,
I can,
I understand that level of backlash.
I don't understand
people that just feel that their party is just completely unflawed.
I don't understand that.
Um,
having said that,
I think Kanya just has an album coming out and MTV doesn't exist anymore.
And,
um,
that people at his level,
they create controversies as a way to get free promotion.
That's what I think.
I don't,
I don't take it seriously and nor do I give a shit what his political
affiliation is.
I don't,
I don't care.
I don't care that you're a good feel.
Europe.
I get it.
You know,
you,
a lot of people become Republican when they make money and then they realize how
much money you have to fucking give away and fucking taxes.
Um,
if you actually had the audacity to become successful and then all of a sudden
you have to fucking,
you know,
you have to pay for everybody else,
which I'm all for helping people out.
But my thing is,
if you're sitting around not doing shit,
you know,
I told you a long time ago,
I,
you know,
this person in my life was kept hitting me up for money and I finally had to
say,
the guy just pant this into,
if you're in a hole and you're reaching up,
I will pull you out of it.
But if you've faced down and it digging it deeper every fucking day,
I mean,
what am I supposed to do?
I'm throwing money into that.
You know,
you want to keep doing fucking drugs and I'm also supposed to give you money,
get,
get you fucking life together and,
and help yourself out and I'll help you out,
you know?
So I see,
you know,
I see all sides of the shit,
and sometimes I land,
you know,
it's funny out here in Hollywood,
people think,
you know,
someone was telling me so people think he voted for Trump,
which I,
I didn't.
Um,
I,
I kind of see like a,
I dunno,
it's,
it's really,
uh,
a situation to situation,
decision,
you know what I mean?
Sometimes you punched,
sometimes you go for it on fourth down.
You know,
that was depends on where you are in the field that you got.
You have to look at it that way.
You can't just a hundred percent,
but golf lord every fucking time or were put kicking it away every fucking time.
Um,
so I,
I,
you know,
I'm old school where I respect the,
I'm just happy,
sir,
that you're voting,
that you're politically active and you're fucking paying attention.
That's a lot more than I can say for myself.
Said,
God bless you.
Um,
but as far as Kanye,
all of a sudden becoming Republican,
uh,
I don't buy because I'm in show business and that looks like a big fucking,
that looks like wrestling when all of a sudden the hulk became the bad guy.
And then eventually he's going to be shaking the blond hair.
We're in the fucking orange and yellow panties again.
You know.
All right.
Girlfriend wants to have sex before marriage trunks.
I should say a dear mister burn.
I'm 16 years old,
still going through high school.
I have a little problem with my relationship I'm having with this girl I met.
Uh,
but here's a little backstory about it.
Okay.
About a year ago,
one of my friends got a girl pregnant,
and let's just say during that time,
my friend went through some hard time knowing he was going to be a father to the
point he tried to kill himself but failed.
Know Jesus Christ.
This guy can't get anything right.
You can't put a condom on,
right.
He can fucking off himself.
Two days after his attempt,
he found out that the baby didn't make it.
Uh,
ending up in a miscarriage.
Wow.
I have to see what my went friend went through.
I decided I was going to wait until at least 18 to have sex because I don't want
to be like my idiot friend.
Well,
don't you don't want to become a dad at 18 either.
Uh,
wear a fucking condom.
All right.
But here's the story about his story about me and the girl.
I met her at work and we've been dating for about six months now.
And I know what you're going to hear me say next.
Like I really like her and all that bullshit,
but get to the point.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
screen goes black anyway.
She wants to have sex.
Even though I told her I'm planning to wait after I told her that she gave me
that look.
Uh,
three days later she tried to pressure me into it.
I kept saying,
no.
While you're learning,
one of the great fucking secrets about women is,
uh,
whatever the fuck you want them to do.
Say you want to do the exact opposite.
You know what I mean?
And then they will fucking,
it's,
it's unbelievable.
It's like a fucking cat.
We used to go to Calgary,
used to do that fucking pit and you know,
you call a cat,
it just for fucking doesn't come at you.
You blow it off and it's fucking walking towards you.
Um,
anyways,
then she went so far as to cry and sob about me not wanting to have sex with
her.
Also,
I liked the idea of casual sex,
but I want to experience love sex.
Also,
I think this girl lied to me to try to get down my pants.
What do you think lie to you about what?
Bird balls?
Uh,
and stick your Dick Up Your Ass Hole,
Aka go fuck yourself.
Okay.
You kind of all over the map here and you also left out a lot of sentences.
She lied to you.
Like,
I dunno,
I just do what the fuck you want to do.
If what happened to your friend had such a psychological effect on you that you
don't want to have sex,
don't have sex with this person.
That's it.
And women cry and sob all the fucking time to dry to get their fucking way.
It's bullshit.
Okay.
Unless she is slugged him in the arm.
I don't know what the fuck they're crying about.
You know what I mean?
You're crying,
crying.
I could see if you're upset,
if you're depressed,
but you're crying.
Here's the thing,
don't do this.
But this is what I do.
Because I've said that to women.
Like you crying over this,
how old are you?
Watch how quickly the tears stopped and they immediately switched to fucking
anger.
Okay.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
The,
their ability,
how fast they can stop crying and then fucking start yelling at you.
Like I was going back to whenever I cried when I was a kid.
I mean,
I couldn't just stop that,
you know,
I'd be like,
fuck.
And I was still be crying.
They immediately just stop fucking crying.
Bam.
So,
um,
here's the deal,
dude.
You're actually,
what you're doing to this woman is you're actually,
you don't like when you play a video game,
one of those fighting video games and you don't know what you're doing.
You just push a button,
a bunch of buttons and all of a sudden you,
your guy does something special in you,
but you don't know how the fuck you did it.
That's what you're doing with this.
You know,
this is a completely role reversed.
Okay.
She's crying like,
because you're not going to fuck her.
Like you sound like you're in a boy band.
Like you through acting the complete opposite way as of every other guy has.
So mind fucked her that she's acting.
You're,
you're getting treated like you're fucking Justin Bieber Asub Shit.
Um,
yeah,
she's making this all about herself.
She feels fucking rejected.
Cause this is the thing,
women know the power that they have over us and the fact that you at the height
of how you're at the height of where you should not be able to walk away from it
are walking away from it is fucking with her and her level of,
of a,
I dunno,
power,
you know,
I would think this is all so I'm really fucking stupid and don't know shit about
women.
But sometimes I do,
you know,
remember that Mel Gibson movie where he was a conspiracy theorist,
he throughout all these crazy ones,
but every once in a while he was right.
That's how I am with women.
Every in a while I'm fucking right.
So what I will tell you that,
so what I do know is you should do what the fuck you want to do.
All right?
And um,
yeah,
I believe Hootie and the blowfish said it best when they said let her cry.
Okay.
I mean that song later.
Oh crap.
And when someone calls out tomorrow,
lady range,
whatever the fuck he said,
how smart was Darrius Rucker when he got out of that fucking bed?
That was like when the fucking road run,
it just steps off the rock before it fucking crashes to the ground is somehow he
doesn't take the impact.
You know,
now he does the country thing,
right?
Uh,
anyways,
that's the podcast.
Everybody,
um,
I have some work to do today and then I am just shutting this fucking down.
I'm not going to fucking do anything for like three,
four days.
I have to get past this God damn cough.
Um,
I'm coming up on two weeks with us and I don't wanna I don't want to,
you know,
I've never had pneumonia and I don't want to fucking get it,
cause then every time you get it,
it's like every time when she get frostbite,
you know,
every time you open the refrigerator,
your fucking toe start tingling.
I don't want to deal with that for the rest of my life.
All right,
that's the podcast.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
I apologize that it was late,
but,
um,
you know,
I was,
I'm fighting this fucking thing off.
I'm fighting the good fight here.
Everybody.
All right,
I'll check in on your Thursday.
Go Fuck Yourself.